avant que la vidéo commence je profite
d'être dans le thème en vous proposant
une vidéo sur le jeu vidéo pour vous
annoncer l'arrivée d'un nouveau concours
in stand gaming pour participer c'est
très simple
accéder au lien dans la description et
entrez le nom du jeu que vous convoitez
et voilà bonne chance à tous
je suis vraiment désolé que cette vidéo
arrive en retard je crois que je suis
après tout le monde ok alors stop ça
c'était il ya près de deux ans le
premier teaser de breath of the wild
venait de sortir et la hype était à son
paroxysme
et c'est avec un très grand sourire que
nous allons remettre ce sujet au devant
de la scène le temps d'une vidéo la
tradition oblige je vous propose de
revenir sur le second est récent teaser
de zelda breath of the wild 2 sous forme
de trois théories et en compagnie du bg
ultime héros sef et oui toujours par
tendance qu'il s'agit d'explorer
l'univers de zelda
la question du voyage dans le temps et
de plus en plus explicite
je serais même surpris qu'il n'y en ait
pas dans le jeu
le premier teaser nous montrait le
potentiel retour de ganondorf avec une
musique constitué d'une perception
qu'elle était à l'envers
c'était déjà un premier pas vers le
voyage longtemps sauf que là la
thématique est vraiment poussé avec ce
second teaser nous retrouvons une autre
musique avec cette même perception link
possède de nouveaux pouvoirs dont un lui
permettant de faire remonter le temps à
un objet il y a également le plan d'une
flaque redevenant une goutte d'eau qui
d'ailleurs s'enchaînent sur un link en
train de remonter à travers une
plateforme traduisant une certaine
dissonance puisque nous sommes censés
tombé à cause de la gravité et non
remontée quoi bref c'est peut-être
anodin mais nous sommes face à un teaser
est le but d'un teaser c'est de
justement nous créer de l'interrogation
dévoiler des thématiques et certains
éléments du jeu sans véritablement ce
pôle est donc tous ces éléments reliés
au temps ne sont pas là par hasard
ils ont été choisis par nintendo ils ont
voulu
le montrer puis sans oublier la
dissonance entre ce que nous proposait
zelda breath of the wild premier du nom
est ce que nous voyons dans le teaser la
map a clairement évolué il y a
énormément d'îles flottantes qui
n'étaient pas là avant un link qui
semble très différents et comparé au
plan du château qui semble être le même
que celui du premier jeu et bien nous
avons l'impression d'être face à deux
mondes différents
alors voilà pour moi le voyage dans le
temps ce n'est plus la question est ce
que cela va arriver mais plutôt comment
et pourquoi cela va arriver
et bien tout d'abord il faut penser
cohérence de l'univers scénario est
évidemment voir ce que l'on nous a
dévoilé pour mieux tout comprendre déjà
loss of the wild semble nous montrait
une sorte de procéder du post
apocalyptique puisque le jeu nous
propose une ère où hyrule a été dévastée
par gallant le fléau les être du mal
rôde partout
la map est vidée de ses habitants qui
ont été largement réduits et la plupart
des structures sont en ruines
et si l'on suit ce procédé cela
sous-entend qu'il ait eu une époque
hyrule était à son apogée
une aire d'évolution jamais atteinte
auparavant ni après 6 une époque qui est
mentionné par him pas dans le premier
jeu et qui semble se dévoiler dans le
teaser ligne possède des pouvoirs encore
plus le surprenant que ce que nous
proposait la tablette cheick là où il
pouvait l'ambré sur the wave un contrôle
et le métal ou créer de la glace sur de
l'eau par exemple ici il peut faire
remonter le temps à un objet ou même
passer entre des plateformes traduisant
derrière cela une technologie un pouvoir
accru inexistant dans le premier jeu et
pour créer de la cohérence dans
l'univers est lié les deux jeux entre
eux nous ne pouvons pas choisir
n'importe quelle époque
si nous remontons dans le temps il faut
bien avoir conscience que tout est
calculé et réfléchie par nintendo
est ce que don breath of the world on
nous a déjà parlé de ce qu'il s'est
passé il y a cinq cents en non pas du
tout donc se serait-il logique pour la
cohérence du scénario entre les deux
jeux et l'univers de retourner 500 ans
avant breath of the wild
car on ne nous a jamais parlé de cette
époque en revanche il y en a une très
précises qui fait même l'objet d'une
cinématique ses selles
il y a dix mille ans raconté par him pas
et c'est la seule et unique époque qui a
été introduite dans le jeu une époque où
hyrule était à son apogée ou les
gardiens ont été créés et au ganondorf
s'est pris une sacrée dérouillée une
époque clé car apparemment le fléau
n'est plus réapparu depuis jusqu'aux
événements de bressols the wild où ils
ont voulu refaire ce qui a été fait à
l'époque
sauf que tout à fait évidemment bref
tout ça pour vous dire que si nous
devons voyager dans le temps c'est
forcément à cette époque
et si on suit cette logique cela
permettrait d'expliquer pas mal de
choses et la stratégie que possède
nintendo concernant ce deuxième opus
puisque cela permet déjà d'amener un
nouvel lire une d'une autre époque une
époque il y avait des îles flottantes
des tenues plus anciennes comme celles
que portent link des pouvoirs qui
n'existe plus aujourd'hui de nouveaux
ennemis de nouveaux personnages et
cetera un procédé qui doit permettre à
nintendo d'innover et dans la logique il
faut aussi justifié le moyen pour link
de voyager dans une autre époque
nous avons tous fait breath of the wild
nous connaissons ses moindres recoins et
rien ne semble nous permettre de voyager
dans le temps
à moins que effectivement le teaser nous
amène un nouvel endroit
c'est sous le château d'hyrule là où
semblerait se trouvait le corps de
ganondorf et pour théoriser un peu plus
loin nous savions dans le premier jeu
15h20 avait annoncé le retour du fléau
et qu'apparemment la solution pour le
vaincre se trouvaient dans les
entrailles du château les habitants ont
donc creusé et ont trouvé les créatures
divines et les gardiens sauf qu'il
existe une chance qu'il se soit trompé
puisque au final les créatures les
gardiens se sont retournés contre eux et
ganon n'est pas véritablement mort
puisqu'il va faire son retour dans
breath of the wild 2 donc les entrailles
du château signifier possiblement
l'endroit que nous voyons dans le teaser
un endroit encore inconnu pour nous et
qui pourrait symboliser le passage dans
le temps vers l'époque d'il ya dix mille
ans l'endroit où link pourrait également
acquérir ces nouveaux pouvoirs ce qui
s'apparentait à possiblement celui
de l'ancien héros une époque qui va
pouvoir amener des réponses sur pourquoi
il y à gan dorff qui sommeille sous le
château depuis dix mille ans et pourquoi
il n'a pas été véritablement vaincu
[Musique]
s'il ya bien une chose que tout le monde
a remarqué avec ce nouveau teaser c'est
le grand rapprochement qui lie à avec
zelda skyward sword skyward sword est le
premier zelda de la chronologie est
celui qui va nous introduire le concept
de célesbourg une grande ville située
dans les cieux où habitent les îliens
donc évidemment le jeu a instauré la
thématique du ciel dans la saga zelda
avec une map possédant des îles
flottantes un link qui planent à travers
les nuages et bizarrement ce sont des
codes que l'on retrouve dans le teaser
de breath of the wild
sauf qu'il n'ya pas que ça et c'est à se
demander pourquoi ce rapprochement entre
les deux jeux on retrouve tout le délire
psychédélique comme une sorte de rêve où
nous voyons zelda tomber et link qui
tenteraient de la récupérer et pour
aller encore plus loin
si on lit également skyward sword avec
la théorie précédente et bien le g le
seul de la série me semble le proposer
en véritable voyage dans le temps entre
deux époques séparés par plusieurs
centaines voire milliers d'années et là
on ne parle pas d'un voyage de sept ans
comme dans ocarina of time mais de la
présence de véritables portes du temps
reliant passé lointain et futurs sans
oublier tout le délire de vallon du saut
en forme d'entonnoir où étaient logés la
grande statue de la déesse et où le
banni soit l'avatar du néant est enfermé
et celle est lui aussi par un seau et
bien c'est un délire que l'on retrouve
également dans ce qui nous est montré in
via les deux teasers ganondorf est
retenu par un saut un saut situé dans un
creux un peu en forme d'entonnoir juste
en dessous une parcelle de terre qui est
en train de se
soulever je pense que nous sommes en
droit de nous poser certaines questions
et bien je vous avoue que j'ai peut-être
une certaine réponse zelda breath of the
world a toujours fait l'objet d'un
éternel débat autour de sa position dans
la timeline une timeline qui a été
écarté par nintendo concernant le jeu
ils ont toujours été floues et ont renié
cette dernière depuis la sortie de
breath of the wild et bien si c'était
justement car la saga breath of the wild
symbolise une version ultime de la saga
nous avons retrouvé d'innombrables
références aux anciens jeux de la
licence le miroir des ombres le
rangement l'an l'écho goulée cristal de
sel les piafs l'arbre mojo et cetera et
cetera
nous retrouvons des éléments de chaque
jeu situés dans différentes branches de
la timeline est aujourd'hui en nous un
store des éléments de skyward sword
alors et si la saga breath of the wild
était comme une réécriture une fusion de
toute la saga zelda dans un nouvel
univers
car là où cela m'interroge encore plus
ce que s'ils voyagent dans le temps il y
a avec une possible sorte de porte de
temps situé sous le château et bien on
ira à l'aube de l'ère du présent de
breath of the way il y a dix mille ans
donc tout le début de la légende de
zelda dans cette nouvelle saga est ce qu
elle nous ressort dès le premier jeu de
la licence chronologiquement parlant lob
de la timeline
on retrouverait encore cette même
symbolique d'ailleurs je pense même que
nous aurons encore d'autres références à
skyward sword qui ne sont toujours pas
dévoilé mais par exemple nous avons la
présence de feuilles en quelque sorte
dans breath of the wild l'épée interagit
tout seul
traduisant
l'idée qu'elle possède un esprit à
l'intérieur et justement moi je vous
avoue que pour un breath of the way the
un petit giraille me ferait plaisir ou
du moins une entité cherchant à
réveiller ganondorf histoire d'avoir un
méchant secondaire mais bon vu que le
cadavre de ganondorf a été montré
plusieurs fois c'est bien lui la star
donc cela reste à méditer et à oui
évidemment si skyward sword sort
maintenant sur switch ce n'est pas trop
un hasard je pense stratégie marketing
toi même tu connais par rapport à tout
ce que nous savons par rapport à tout ce
que nous avons dit j'aimerais que nous
terminions sur le cas de ganondorf que
l'on y revienne plus précisément la
complexité de breath of the wild et
qu'il est un jeu faisant partie de la
saga zelda
donc tout ce qui symbolise son lors son
univers ses références et pourtant il
est si indépendant si détaché de tous
les autres jeux qu'il est très difficile
de le cerner et de le lire par moments
c'est pourquoi je penche de plus en plus
pour une réécriture de la saga les jeux
zelda sont iconique depuis toujours mais
ce sont trop préciser avec le temps
l'exemple ultime et skyward sword
justement le dernier gros zelda en date
avant breath of the web ou nintendo à
viser carrément une niche de joueurs
expérimentés puisque ils justifient
toute la timeline et l'expliquent là
avec la nintendo switch qui a fait un
carton énorme
nintendo a eu l'occasion de remanier
zelda casser les codes de la saga est
donc proposé de nouvelles bases pour
notamment attirer des joueurs plus qu
asus atteindre le mind stream et ils ont
réussi
et s'il ya bien un élément qui démontre
parfaitement cette nouvelle stratégie
c'est la triforce artefacts ultime et
principal de la saga zelda elle est
totalement ignorée dans breath of the
wild
alors qu'elle est partout à la fois les
seuls moments où elle apparaît séquence
zelda déclenché son pouvoir
est ce que cela signifie donc que zelda
possède la triforce entière et qu'en
est-il de link ou encore ganondorf qui
ont normalement celle du courage et de
la force
plusieurs questions qui sont légitimes
de se poser et bien et si nous avions
les réponses dans breath of the wild 2
ce que je veux dire c'est que ça y est
nintendo a innové breath of the wild a
retracé une nouvelle histoire zelda un
nouveau hyrule il va maintenant être
temps de rentrer dans le concret avec ce
second opus
fini les présentations fini l'effet de
surprise et galant dorff en est déjà une
preuve à lui tout seul faire revenir à
mon agonie ce taux pareils relate alors
non négligeable il va falloir le
justifier concernant les intentions de
ce dernier et par rapport au voyage dans
le temps qu'il y a dix mille ans
ganondorf est aujourd'hui une momie du
coup logiquement qu'est-ce qu'il
chercherait à faire a retrouvé son corps
d'antan et ses pouvoirs il va chercher à
se restaurer c'est idiot 1 mais je ne
suis pas sûr qu'une simple momie en
bosse finale du jeu soient réellement
attrayant pour l'expérience du joueur
surtout qu'on sait qui il est réellement
et du coup il ya moyen de relier ceci au
voyage dans le temps à zelda ou encore
la triforce
le voyage dans le temps traduit un
retour en arrière
un retour pour ganondorf lui permettant
de retrouver sa forme de l'époque mais
surtout si zelda disparaît comme semble
le montrer les teasers et puis même je
ne pense pas qu'on va se coltiner zelda
tout le long du jeu et bien canon d'or
pourraient avoir besoin d'elle pour
récupérer la triforce une mécanique qui
permettrait à ganondorf de retrouver sa
force d'antan et de le rendre encore
plus dangereux que dans breath of the
wild 1 sans oublier une certaine phase
de combat de boss final que l'on
retrouve dans quelques jeux zelda et si
ganondorf cherchait à acquérir le corps
de zelda pour justement la posséder une
thématique présente dans skyward sword
ou schirrhein a besoin de zelda pour
réveiller l'avatar du néant et donc une
nouvelle liaison avec la théorie
précédente
ou bien tout simplement comme dans
spirit tracks où le roi démon cherche à
posséder zelda pour devenir un être
ultime grâce à ses pouvoirs
traduisant derrière cela un combat où
nous affronterions zelda posséder une
référence
que l'on connaît tous dans tous les cas
il ya de grandes chances pour la
cohérence de l'univers que le scénario
de la saga breath of the wild se précise
la fin du jeu nous montre qu'il n'y a
plus rien on y roule pour devenir une
menace et ganondorf semble revenir
il faut donc rentrer dans le détail et
nous montrer ce qu'il s'est passé il y a
dix mille ans la nouvelle origines de la
saga est ce que le héros de l'époque à
utiliser la triforce pour emprisonner
ganondorf pendant deal
ce qui expliquerait l'absence de cette
dernière depuis tout ce temps et bien à
vous de me dire en commentaire
d'ailleurs petit mot sur un élément dont
je voulais vous parler mais que j'ai
totalement omis de mettre dans mon
développement
ganondorf et link sont sapés exactement
pareil et ce n'est pas négligeable
certains pensaient que ganondorf était
le héros de l'époque bon moi je vous
avoue que j'ai du mal à y croire
personnellement mais et si ganondorf
était plutôt le champion gay rudeau de
l'époque ce qui expliquerait la tunique
similaire censée être celle des
champions
imaginez un seul instant ganondorf
champion des gués rudeau contrôlant
vannes à boris avant de se rebeller et
donc créer une crainte des hommes chez
les femmes guérido qui les ont banni est
ce encore dix mille ans plus tard cela
reste à méditer
enfin voilà ce fut un véritable plaisir
de reparler de breath of the wild
évidemment je vous ai proposé ma version
du teaser tout ce que je vous raconte ne
traduit que main simple pensée
personnelle
peut-être que j'ai faux sur toute la
ligne mais je trouve que ça mérite débat
la tradition est respectée le trois
théories et honoré et je remercie heroes
sève de m'avoir accompagné n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner à sa chaîne bien
évidemment le bouc fait toujours un
travail de grande qualité
quant à moi merci à ceux qui laisseront
un petit bout ce bleu qui laisseront un
petit commentaire
et surtout qui s'abonneront à la chaîne
retrouvez moi sur les réseaux écoutez
c'était argot rock et que le lionheart
soit avec vous allez ciao thomas
[Musique]